you turn une petite ville qui a perdu sa
tranquillité loot en est au coeur de la
réserve autochtone de football la ville
est envahi des centaines de camions
chaque jour et c'est sans compter les
traits tout ce qu'il faut pour sortir le
pétrole déplaire
le tiers de la production du nord des
etats-unis est puisée sur le territoire
autochtone des puits on en voit partout
nouvelle ruée vers l'or noir qui attire
bien des gens et une autre génération de
cabre l'argent c'est la seule chose
qu'il l'a poussé à venir au dakota du
nord en plein hiver il n'a pas encore
d'emploi payant mais se dit heureux dans
une cabane au qui empestent de la
friture le patron arrivée de las vegas
garde aussi le sourire
il finira bien par trouver un édifice
convenable pour servir ses clients
la manne est il sain qu'il y à beaucoup
d'argent à newton et bien des occasions
d'affaires
il faut nourrir coiffer divertir tous
ces gens est faux de logement adéquat on
s'entasse là où on peut
le chef de la police locale s'attend à
ce que la population double cette année
le calme ne l'avait attiré newton
mais aujourd'hui ces agents sont occupés
comme jamais armes à feu drogues dures
prostitution pour les foires on y
rapporte autant de crimes que dans une
ville 15 fois plus peuplés le bon
pétrolier entraînent aussi une série de
problèmes environnementaux
prenez cette flamme et du gaz naturel il
est dans le sol à la même place que le
pétrole et il sort en même temps mais
comme le dakota du nord est mal équipé
pour stocker tout ce gaz est pour le
vendre sur les marchés on brûle jusqu'à
la moitié de ce qui sort essentiellement
c'est comme si on chauffait la plaine
beaucoup s'inquiètent aussi pour l'eau
potable
on utilise énormément d'eau pour
extraire le pétrole par facturation
une eau qui devient très toxique ait
seulement il y a eu des fuites et des
versements
cet avocat a dit qu'on a retrouvé du
diesel dans un puits qui alimente
quelques centaines de personnes
il y a aussi les tonnes de déchets
toxiques qui ne sont pas toujours
entreposés correctement au printemps
dernier on a découvert dépotoir
improvisée dans un immeuble à l'abandon
face l'argent neuf c'est bien beau lance
26 gillett mais saviez un prix très
élevé
bien sûr le pétrole fait aussi des
heureux comme cette grand-mère une
compagnie a installé un puits sur la
terre familiale
elle peut donc gâtés ces petits enfants
avec les milliers de dollars en
redevances versées chaque mois
mais la plupart des résidents de la
réserve de football ne reçoivent rien
parce qu'ils ne possèdent pas de terre
il compte donc sur le gouvernement
autochtone qui touchent des centaines de
millions de dollars en redevances mais
les soupçons de collusion et
d'incompétence sont nombreux la nouvelle
administration a promis plus de
transparence la bande compte aussi sur
sa propre compagnie d'exploitation
pétrolière leur slogan la souveraineté
grâce au baril de pétrole le pdg par
d'investir des millions de dollars en
éducation en santé autochtone de val est
surveillé de près et juge les autorités
mal préparée pour recevoir autant
d'argent
les voix des pensées sans trop compter
sans vraiment penser à ceux qui seront
encore là lorsque tous ces puits seront
asséchées ici est né du mont-bart en
radio canada newton